好,我今天來講一個很多人都有遇過的問題
就是如果發現自己有不知道為什麼進的單要怎麼辦
然後我一邊錄的時候就
就蠻有趣的,順便同時一邊打夜盤的四百口
然後看就是會不會剛好有進場這樣子
然後就
就是有趣啊,剛好可以看打單
那現在馬上出現了一個四百口
WOWOWOWOW
然後又再出現了一個
那我現在是還沒有掛啦
這邊是可以掛一個
三百的空單,不過我覺得這個
下一根應該會也是大量,所以我就等下一根再掛
看這個會不會收紅K
如果收紅K我就掛一個三一四的空單
哇結果變黑K
如果是紅K的話,收K的時候我就掛一個
減三一四的出價單
然後我現在就是看秒數嘛,等收K嘛
OK,收紅K
那這樣應該蠻容易進的
然後現在就算
如果知道的話要多少停損嘛
這個是三一四到
三二六
所以是
12點的
Risk
然後
三一四扣
扣24是
所以如果
如果進場的時候就
當然第一件事情是先掛停損
如果進場第一件事就是馬上掛停損
然後再去掛停
好像也蠻有趣的
就是
好吧,沒進到
然後就反正你滑鼠就放在這邊嘛
就是
進場第一點是就是馬上掛上停損
那就看會不會進到
然後下一個
低點是一樣嘛
而且口述也不夠
所以就
不用改進場點
好吧
反正就
我一直不知道會不會進到
這樣我很難
同時
講其他的事情
好
就是我們有時候會
不小心
就是第二天起來
然後發現
怎麼昨天有
有一個
自己不知道的持場
那這是
真實的故事啦
剛好有一個人問我
就是他
第二天早上起來的時候發現
怎麼有一個
昨天的空單
他睡覺的時候以為自己是空手
然後
早上醒來發現他自己持有一個空單
然後那個空單已經虧損10萬
就是
第二天是跳空開高
然後他睡覺之後是
漲上去
怎麼一直進不到
唉唷唉唷快要進到喔
然後他就
當時就很緊張啊
怎麼會有一個
虧損10萬的空單
他就馬上
把那個
那一單給
品倉掉了
好像快要進到喔
然後他出掉之後呢
唉唷唉唷唉唷
應該要
唉唷
又沒進到
唉唷這一直在干擾我講故事
然後他把那個
空單停損10萬塊出掉之後
這個後來行情就
一路下跌
然後又跌回他的
空單進場的成本價
然後他就
他就覺得很歐啊
唉唷
是不是應該要
再等一下
等那個空單看會不會下跌
跌回成本價再出就好
那大家覺得到
在這邊大家可以
這個思考一下你覺得
他
看到那個單然後很緊張馬上把它出掉是對的嗎
還是他應該要等一下看會不會跌回來
因為後來是跌回來了
那當然答案就是
他當下馬上把它出掉是對的
因為
好我馬上掛上停損
因為當時他沒有辦法知道會不會
就是
等一下我先下去掛一下停滴
因為當時他不知道會不會那個嘛
他不知道
就是他不知道自己進場那時候是什麼樣的情況
那
如果
他繼續持有空單的話就
等於是表示
他覺得
接下來有可能會跌嘛
那如果他只是在那邊等說看會不會
這個跌回去的話
那
那如果行情往上上漲的話
他也不知道要怎麼停損
然後如果
往下下跌
當然他可能是成本價才出
但是
基本上他就是
等於是一個
他不知道現在是什麼情況
然後
1/2的
瞎堵嘛
那這樣當然就不是
這個
可以接受的事情
看我還是
會一直很想要看
那個成交明細現在發生什麼事情
好反正我現在就兩邊掛了
那
如果有出現新的爆大量的話我才會需要
就是
調整
調整我的停損停滴位置
現在我
現在我就是
掛在這邊然後
看停損跟停滴哪個先達到
好所以就是
如果
你
不知道你自己那單進場的
那個
理由是什麼
或是
那單進場理由
消失了
或是那單根本就沒有進場理由的話
你就應該馬上把那單品藏掉
那
會出現
不知道為什麼持有的
這個
單子在手上
通常
最常見的就是
你看現在
上面是掛一個
停損
出價單
然後下面
還好我有檢查
這個掛錯了
停力要掛限價單
那
如果其中一邊成交之後
有時候
你會忘記去刪掉另外一邊的單子
就是
另外一邊的單子
就是你有時候會忘記去刪掉另外一邊的單
那如果你
一邊成交了然後忘記刪掉另外一邊的單子的話
有可能
就是
後來行情又走到那個地方然後又打到了
那
那可能就會
那個
就是會
會變成一個
沒有
停損
的持單
那這樣的話就
非常不好
就是
就是每一單都應該要有停損來保護他
那這個是最
最有可能發生的情況
那
就是
比較少見的情況就是
你
不知道
就是
其實根本就沒有出掉
然後你以為出掉了
但是這個
其實真的有點難
因為
因為有沒有成交
正常來說應該是非常明顯
就是
你看我現在這樣講故事都有點講不清楚
因為我一直在看
他往上跟往下會不會成交
然後會不會出現新的爆發量
要
我把這單給重新
就是
調整他的進場跟出場的位置
那
那所以我就一直去看他嘛
那如果
就是
你不太會
其實沒有成交
然後以為自己成交啦
這樣就有點太瞎了
好吧希望這單趕快出掉
讓我可以正常的好好講故事
我
我可以感受到我自己
講話
超級坑坑巴巴的
真的是講都講不清楚
我看一下
OK
好然後
然後
好我是在看
我是在看325是不是最高點啦
然後325是夜盤最高點
那現在我已經獲利一萬五了嘛
我在看我要不要開寶本
那因為
因為325是夜盤最高點
所以我就不開寶本
就是
如果創新高我再停順
好然後
我剛才講什麼
喔就是
通常
這個
沒有出到是因為
就是發現
就是其中一邊
成交然後另外一邊忘記刪掉
我還是一直去看那個成交明星
那
所以
就是
內單是沒有進場理由的嘛
所以就應該要馬上把內單給
給出掉
那如果
就是
趕快還是一直看
趕快出一出來
讓我好好講好不好
好
那如果其中一邊成交的時候應該怎樣呢
就是不管是
停損或停歸
其中一邊成交了
就應該要馬上
把另外一邊刪掉
就是
例如說這邊往上
打到上面
停損出廠
那我就應該
趕快按下面把買單全部取消
那如果是
那個
停歸打到的話
那就
應該要馬上把這個
NIT單給刪掉
就是上面這個
就是
是一個
就是養成一個
SOP習慣啦
就是一邊成交了
把另外一邊刪掉
哇又漲上去了
然後另外一個
要養成的習慣就是
你要把你的閃電下單關掉之前
把下面的
四個都按一次
就是
把
出價全部刪掉
買單全部刪掉
賣單全部刪掉
然後
這個
賣單的NIT也全部刪掉
就是四個都各按一次
哇又漲回來
好
那這個是
就是養成一個習慣
第一個是
一進場的時候馬上掛停損
然後停損跟停利
其中一個打到之後
去把另外一個要馬上刪掉
然後另外一個是關掉
閃電下單之前把
這四個券都各按一次
然後
另外一個要講的是
就是
一個類似的概念啦
就是如果是
股票的話
有時候有些人他那個APP打開來一看
哇
十幾檔股票
就是
有時候他
他甚至有的股票他都
忘記那家公司
到底是幹嘛的
然後也不記得
自己那個進場的理由是什麼
因為
其實有些人可能他就是
什麼
什麼隔壁的
這個王大媽跟他說
這個股票好像不錯
然後聽說是有一個
什麼公司高層給他的一個消息
喔那不錯
好那我就跟著王大媽買一下
就是
甚至都不知道
那個持有的理由是什麼
那
那像這種
如果你發現你的
池倉裡面十幾支
然後有這樣的股票的話
那你不但應該
把這些持股全部出清
而且
你可能應該暫時退出股市
然後
學一些
就是
就是完整的交易模式
然後再
再來繼續交易
因為
就表示
你的那個
交易模式幾乎是完全瞎堵
哇
超過成本價值上
好那因為
我這個
這單停損是在創新高
所以我是沒有開寶本
雖然中間獲利是
有超過一倍的RISK
一倍的RISK是12嘛
那
不過因為
因為創新高所以
我沒有
我是不會開寶本
我的狗在後面抓那個
抓他的墊子
好我剛剛講什麼
我剛剛說
如果一單的
就是
十單是完全沒有理由的話
那你就應該把它品嚐掉
那所以如果你不小心發現
你有你完全不知道為什麼持有的
東西你就應該把它除一除
好
這單感覺等了有點久
看一下群柱講什麼
好吧
有時候這種一單要等很久
好了
好啦
那
為了避免這個影片後面都是沒用的時間
這個大家就
自己去看
這單後來是停損還是停利
如果先打到
那6就是停損
然後
先打到290就是停利
如果中間出現新的爆打量
就是其他的情況
也有可能是其他的情況
因為我只是想要一邊打
然後一邊
一邊講個故事啦
感覺這樣比較有趣嘛
背景有一件事情在發生
但是
好像會有點影響我講話
現在我現在不看成交迷信
我講話就比較順一點
可是剛剛我一直在看成交迷信
會不會有新的爆打量
然後就
就一直
講話卡卡的這樣
唉算了
感覺大家可能會想知道結局是什麼
好我再等5分鐘好不好
到10點
如果到10點這單還沒出掉
這個影片就太長了
我今天去玩那個寬板滑水
還蠻好玩的
就是
它是一個
有點像是衝浪
就是站在一個板子上面
然後
前面掛一條線
會有一部那個
遊艇在那邊衝來衝去
就是
簡單版的衝浪
因為我之前去玩衝浪
我已經是
游泳救生員
應該算很會游泳
但我第一次玩衝浪
還是
就是幾乎站不了
就站了幾秒
馬上就掉下來
然後掉到水衣
然後就只好
花很久的時間
再
游回外面
然後就站到板子上面
站個
一兩秒
然後就掉下去
那如果是那個
有遊艇在那的話
難度不是很高
然後又
比較好玩
然後我們
就是
今天也有一個
女生去
而且是平常
應該沒有
什麼在運動的女生
然後
她也滑了起來
所以
就是
應該是
新手也蠻
蠻簡單
就可以滑起來
300一直跌不下去
看一下台積電現在是怎樣
台積電90塊了
我說美股的台積電
喔然後平常
我的閃電下單跟
跟XQ不會放在同一個畫面
因為這樣子
會擋住一部分的XQ嘛
不過
因為我要錄影
所以就把它放在同一個畫面
不然的話
就是你應該是要把它放在不同的螢幕
這個自己擋到自己也不太好
不然的話
自己擋到自己也不太好
所以辦現在是
在
在高點
到窮也漲
每股市大指數現在都是在漲
好
我已經完全不知道要講什麼了
就是
就是連
早上去玩寬版都講
好吧
那我就先把這個影片結束了
這個應該大家還是有覺得
有有有有有趣啦
有嗎
拜拜